Bonjour à tous, aujourd’hui on va parler
de ce qui peut être considéré comme LE
plus gros problème conceptuel de la mécanique
quantique, ce qu’on appelle le problème
de la mesure.
Alors ça peut paraitre étrange de dire que
la mécanique quantique a un problème.
Après tout c’est la théorie physique probablement
la mieux confirmée expérimentalement.
De la chimie quantique jusqu’aux accélérateurs
de particules en passant par la physique du
solide, ses prédictions collent remarquablement
à ce qu’on peut observer dans les diverses
expériences qu’on a pu imaginer.
Alors c’est quoi ce problème de la mesure.
Comme j’ai l’ai dit c’est un problème
conceptuel, une sorte d’incohérence dans
la théorie.
Cette incohérence ne pose absolument aucun
souci en pratique, quand on fait des expériences,
mais soulève tout un tas de questions sur
l’interprétation qu’on peut faire de
la mécanique quantique.
Et bien qu’on l’utilise avec succès depuis
un siècle, c’est à cause du problème
de la mesure, qu’aujourd’hui, on a encore
des tas de physiciens et de philosophes qui
travaillent sur les fondements de la mécanique
quantique, et qui proposent des interprétations
alternatives ou des variations dans son formalisme.
Le but de la vidéo d’aujourd’hui, ça
va être de vous présenter ce problème de
la mesure, et de vous esquisser quelques unes
des solutions possibles, sachant que j’essayerai
de faire une vidéo dédiée sur chacune de
ces théories ou interprétations candidates.
Alors c’est parti.
[jingle]
Pour commencer, il va falloir que j’explique
grossièrement comment on fait de la mécanique
quantique.
On va pas se mentir, si vous n’en avez jamais
fait, le formalisme mathématique peut être
un peu rebutant, et je ne vais donc pas trop
rentrer dans les détails techniques.
Mais je vais essayer de vous présenter la
façon dont on utilise la mécanique quantique
en faisant la comparaison avec la mécanique
non-quantique, celle qu’on apprend au lycée
et qu’on appelle la mécanique classique.
Alors imaginez un objet du quotidien, disons
une balle de tennis.
Pour faire simple, on va la considérer comme
un objet ponctuel, on fait souvent ça en
physique.
Si je considère cette balle ponctuelle à
un certain instant t, de quelles informations
ai-je besoin pour décrire complètement son
état.
On peut en imaginer plein, mais ce qui va
nous intéresser ce sont les informations
sur son état qui sont indispensable à prédire
son avenir, à calculer sa trajectoire future.
[BALLE Bon déjà il nous faut connaître
sa position, histoire de savoir où elle est
cette balle.
On va noter la position X.
Bon mais ça ne suffit pas, si vous voulez
anticiper la trajectoire, il vous faut aussi
connaître sa vitesse, notons la V.
Normalement une fois que vous avez ces deux
informations, X et V, vous êtes bon, vous
savez qu’il faut savoir sur l’état de
la balle de tennis.
De façon générale en mécanique classique,
quand on a un système ponctuel, la donnée
de la position et de la vitesse à un instant
t, c’est l’état de ce système à cet
instant.]
Maintenant si je veux effectivement prédire,
anticiper, l’évolution de la balle, sa
trajectoire, à partir de son état actuel,
qu’est-ce que je fais ? Eh bien je n’ai
plus qu’à appliquer la fameuse équation
de Newton.
[NEWTON Disons que je connaisse X et V à
l’instant 0, ensuite j’utilise la formule
qui dit que la somme des forces est égale
à la masse fois l’accélération.
F = m a.
D’ailleurs on va plutôt l’écrire a = F
/ m.
Et grâce à ça je peux si je veux calculer
l’évolution de la vitesse et de la position,
et donc anticiper la trajectoire de la balle.
Evidemment ça implique de connaitre F, c’est
à dire l’ensemble des influences extérieures
qui vont s’exercer sur ma balle : la gravité,
peut-être les frottements, etc.
Mais si je connais F avec une précision suffisante,
je peux calculer l’évolution de mon système.]
Donc on peut résumer la mécanique classique
comme ça : l’état à un instant t, c’est
position et vitesse, et la règle d’évolution,
c’est la loi de Newton.
Très bien.
Eh bien la mécanique quantique c’est presque
pareil, avec des maths un peu plus compliquées.
[ETATQ Pour décrire l’état d’un système
quantique, disons une particule, on n’utilise
pas simplement sa position ou sa vitesse,
mais un truc plus compliqué qu’on appelle
la fonction d’onde.
Je vous épargne les détails mathématiques,
il suffit de savoir que ça existe.
La fonction d’onde est très souvent notée
avec la lettre grecque Psi.
On parle aussi parfois d’état quantique,
et l’état va dépendre de l’instant t
qu’on considère.
On note donc Psi(t).
Et pour savoir comment cet état va évoluer,
on va utiliser un pendant de l’analogue
quantique de l’équation de Newton, c’est
la fameuse équation de Schrödinger.
Pareil, je vous la montre sans vous détailler
ce qu’elle veut dire.
Mais on peut résumer en disant qu’à gauche
c’est l’évolution de l’état, et à
droite, la lettre H, c’est ce qui contient
toutes les influences extérieures.
On appelle ça le Hamiltonien, et il joue
en gros le même rôle que F dans l’équation
de Newton.
Et donc comme pour la mécanique classique,
si vous connaissez l’état du système à
l’instant initial 0, et que vous savez quantifier
les influences extérieures, avec le Hamiltonien
H, vous pouvez calculer l’évolution de
la fonction d’onde.
Ce que va devenir Psi(t), l’état quantique
du système.]
Voilà, conceptuellement c’est pas si compliqué
la mécanique quantique.
Un état pour décrire le système à un instant
t, et une équation d’évolution de cet
état.
Ca ressemble à la mécanique classique ou
encore à d’autres théories physiques comme
la mécanique des fluides ou l’électromagnétisme.
Et s’il n’y avait que ça, il n’y aurait
aucun problème conceptuel avec la mécanique
quantique.
Mais il n’y a pas que ça.
En mécanique quantique, il y a la question
de la mesure.
Alors voyons déjà en mécanique classique,
comment ça se passe les mesures.
[OBSERVABLES Eh bien c’est pas du tout un
problème.
Quand on a un système, on peut mesurer des
trucs à son sujet, comme sa position, sa
vitesse, son énergie cinétique, son moment
cinétique.
Ce sont des quantités qui sont fonction de
l’état du système, qui se calculent à
partir de X et V.
On va appeler ça des observables.
Et donc à tout instant, quel que soit l’état
de notre système, les observables ont des
valeurs bien définies qui dépendent de l’état.
Après pour accéder à ces valeurs, pour
faire une mesure correcte, expérimentalement
ça peut être compliqué.
On peut être plus ou moins précis, et perturber
plus ou moins le système en le mesurant,
mais il n’y a aucune difficulté conceptuelle.
En mécanique quantique, c’est différent.
On peut considérer les mêmes observables,
l’énergie, la position, le moment cinétique…mais,
cette fois, pour un état du système donné,
pour une certaine fonction d’onde, elle
n’ont pas toujours des valeurs bien définies.
Et la cause de cela, c’est le fameux principe
de superposition.]
Ce principe, qui est au coeur de la mécanique
quantique, nous dit que si vous prenez deux
états quantiques possibles pour un système,
alors un autre état qui serait la somme des
deux autres sera aussi un état quantique
possible.
Ça parait être une règle assez bénigne,
mais en fait pas du tout.
[SUPERPOSITION Regardez, imaginez que j’ai
un état possible pour un électron, je vais
l’appeler Psi_1, et supposons que quand
l’électron est dans l’état Psi_1 son
énergie soit E_1.
Maintenant imaginons un autre état quantique
Psi_2, dont l’énergie serait E_2.
Le principe de superposition nous dit que
l’état superposé Psi_1 + Psi_2 doit aussi
exister, que c’est forcément un état valide.
Il est physiquement possible qu’un électron
soit dans l’état Psi_1 + Psi_2.
Alors pourquoi pas, mais du coup ce serait
quoi l’énergie de l’électron quand il
est dans cet état superposé, ce serait genre
la somme ou la moyenne de E1 et E2 ? Eh bien
non, quand on fait l’expérience c’est
pas du tout ce qu’il se passe.]
[PROBAS Si vous avez un électron dans l’état
Psi_1 + Psi_2, et que vous mesurez son énergie
vous allez trouver E_1 avec 50% de probabilité,
et E_2 avec 50% de probabilité.
Ca veut dire que si vous faites la même expérience
plein de fois avec plein d’électrons dans
le même état Psi_1 + Psi_2 au départ, vous
aurez en moyenne moitié de résultats E1
et moitié de résultats E2.
Et on peut même faire des superpositions
d’états avec des coefficients, comme dans
un cocktail, mettre un peu plus de l’un
ou de l’autre.
Deux fois Psi_1 et 6 fois Psi_2 par exemple,
et ça va faire varier les probabilités.
Il y a une formule qui décrit précisément
les probabilités d’obtenir tel ou tel résultat
en fonction des coefficients de la superposition,
et on appelle ça la règle de Born, en hommage
au physicien allemand Max Born.
]
Contrairement à ce qu’il se passe en mécanique
classique, la mesure quantique est probabiliste,
et ce même si votre appareil de mesure est
parfait et votre méthode de mesure impeccable.
Quand un système est dans un certain état,
les mesures n’ont pas forcément un résultat
bien défini, il y a comme une part de hasard
dans le résultat obtenu.
Evidemment quand on présente les choses comme
ça, on peut penser qu’il n’y a rien de
mystérieux là-dedans.
Je vous dit que si on refait l’expérience
plein de fois avec plein d’électrons dans
l’état Psi_1 + Psi_2 on aura 50/50 des
deux possibilités.
Mais peut-être que je suis juste ignorant
de l’état réel, caché, des électrons.
[PILE/FACE C’est comme quand je tire à
pile ou face, tant que je ne regarde pas ma
pièce, je peux toujours dire qu’elle est
dans l’état superposé pile + face.
Et que quand je regarde je découvre son véritable
état et dans 50% des cas c’est pile, et
dans 50% des cas c’est face.
Mais avec une pièce, le résultat était
déjà intrinsèquement là.
La pièce *était* dans un certain état,
juste j’ignorais lequel.
L’observation révèle juste un truc qui
m’était caché.]
Avec mes électrons quantiques, on pourrait
penser que c’est ce qu’il se passe.
Peut-être que quand je crois qu’ils sont
tous dans l’état Psi1 + Psi2, en réalité
ça n’est pas le cas.
[SUPERPOSITION Peut-être que dès le départ,
certains sont en fait vraiment déjà dans
l’état Psi1 et d’autres vraiment Psi2,
et donc qu’ils ont une énergie bien définie
dès le départ, simplement je ne la connais
pas et je la découvre ensuite, et j’ai
50/50.]
Eh bien non cet image est fausse, les électrons
ne sont pas à l’avance soit dans l’un
soit dans l’autre, ils sont vraiment dans
l’état superposé.
Et si on sait que ce principe de superposition
quantique existe vraiment, c’est grâce
au phénomène d’interférences quantiques.
Pour le voir, pensez à ce qui est l’expérience
la plus emblématique de la mécanique quantique,
l’expérience des fentes d’Young.
J’ai déjà fait une vidéo dessus, mais
je vous la résume à grands traits.
[YOUNG Si vous envoyez des balles sur un écran
percé de deux grosses fentes et que vous
mettez un écran derrière pour visualiser
les impacts, vous allez observer qu’ils
se regroupent en deux ensembles, un pour chaque
fente.
Chaque balle est passée soit par une fente,
soit par l’autre.
Mais si vous faites ça avec des électrons,
vous allez voir que les impacts ne correspondent
pas à deux tâches, mais dessinent progressivement
une alternance de bandes noires avec et sans
impacts, qu’on appelle une figure d’interférences.
Cette figure ne peut pas du tout s’expliquer
en supposant que chaque électron est passé
soit par une fente, soit par l’autre.
Elle trahit un état de superposition quantique,
c’est-à-dire le fait que certaines propriétés
sont non-définies, et n’acquièrent une
valeur que lors du processus de mesure.]
On sait aujourd’hui réaliser expérimentalement
des phénomènes d’interférences quantiques
dans un tout un tas d’autres situations,
par exemple avec des photons uniques dans
un interféromètre.
J’en parlais dans cette vidéo.
Et la conclusion est toujours la même.
La présence d’interférence est la signature
la superposition, l’existence des deux composantes
de l’état superposé.
S’il n’y avait pas cela, si un système
était dès le départ soit dans l’un, soit
dans l’autre, il n’y aurait pas d’interférences.
Bien donc concluons sur la différence entre
mesure en mécanique classique et mesure quantique.
En mécanique quantique, si on mesure une
certaine propriété d’un système quantique,
une observable, le résultat va être en général
probabiliste, obéissant à la règle de Born,
et on sait que ce sont des vrais superpositions
grâce au phénomène d’interférences.
Alors pourquoi pas, c’est déjà assez perturbant.
Mais il faut quand même ajouter une tout
dernière remarque.
[REMESURE Reprenons mes électrons dont la
mesure d’énergie donne soit E1 soit E2
avec 50% de chance.
Si on s’amuse à remesurer immédiatement
l’énergie de chaque électron tout de suite
après, qu’est-ce qu’on obtient ? Eh bien
le résultat précédent sera toujours confirmé.
Si vous remesurez tout de suite les électrons
qui ont donné E1, ça donnera E1 à 100%,
et si vous remesurez les autres, ça donnera
E2 à 100%.
Plus de probabilités.
Alors ça c’est pas mal, ça veut dire que
quand on a fait une mesure, on peut la répéter
immédiatement et on aura le même résultat.
Plutôt cool et rassurant.
Mais ça veut dire un truc important.
Mon électron qui était dans l’état Psi1
+ Psi2, que j’ai mesuré, j’ai trouvé
E1.
Je sais que si je le remesure tout de suite,
je vais à 100% de chance trouver E1.
Mais en fait ça veut dire qu’il n’est
plus dans l’état Psi1 + Psi2.
En fait il est dans l’état Psi1 tout court.
Donc quand on a fait la première mesure et
qu’on a trouvé E1, ça a en fait transformé
mon électron pour l’envoyer dans l’état
Psi1.
Et pareil pour les électrons qu’on a mesuré
avec l’énergie E2, ils ne sont plus dans
un état d’énergie superposé, ils sont
dans l’état Psi2.]
En mécanique quantique, une mesure change
fondamentalement le système auquel elle s’applique,
et le fait en fonction du résultat de mesure
obtenu.
C’est ce qu’on appelle l’effondrement
de la fonction d’onde.
Avant la mesure Psi1 + Psi2, après la mesure
soit Psi1, soit Psi2.
La mesure affecte l’état quantique du système.
Et vous voyez le contraste avec la mécanique
classique.
En mécanique classique si vous mesurez un
système et que vous vous y prenez bien, vous
pouvez le faire sans le perturber plus que
ça.
Je peux mesurer la vitesse d’une voiture
avec un radar sans dramatiquement changer
la trajectoire de la voiture.
En mécanique quantique, ça ne marche pas.
Si vous mesurez la vitesse, l’énergie,
la position d’un objet quantique, vous allez
l’affecter de façon irrémédiable.
Voilà on a là les 3 ingrédients fondamentaux
de la mécanique quantique.
[REGLES L’équation de Schrödinger, qui
dit comment la fonction d’onde évolue,
la règle de Born, qui permet de calculer
les probabilités quand on fait une mesure,
et l’effondrement de la fonction d’onde
qui permet de comprendre ce que devient la
fonction d’onde quand on a un certain résultat.
Et là il y a un gros problème conceptuel.
Vous voyez qu’on a deux règles qui décrivent
les changements de la fonction d’onde.
L’équation de Schrödinger et l’effondrement.
Et ces deux règles sont très différentes.
L’équation de Schrödinger est déterministe
et continue dans le temps, alors que l’effondrement
de la fonction d’onde est probabiliste,
et instantané.
C’est quand même embêtant.
S’il y a deux règles, à quel moment on
applique l’une ou l’autre ?]
On l’a dit, Schrödinger c’est pour les
influences extérieures, et l’effondrement
c’est pour les mesures.
Mais quand on mesure un système, on le soumet
à une interaction, une influence.
Pourquoi on a deux règles, et à partir de
quand on doit appliquer la règle «mesure».
Si j’envoie un photon sur un électron ça
compte comme une interaction ou une mesure
? Schrödinger ou effondrement ?
Eh bien voilà c’est ça le problème de
la mesure en mécanique quantique.
L’existence de ces deux mécanismes, totalement
incompatibles, qui gouvernent l’évolution
de la fonction d’onde.
Et sans indication claire de où s’arrête
Schrödinger et où commence l’effondrement.
Alors ce qui est fou, c’est que cet espèce
de trou conceptuel énorme ne pose quasiment
aucun problème en pratique.
Quand on fait des expériences, on peut se
reposer sur une prescription qu’on appelle
parfois l’interprétation de Copenhague,
en hommage au grand physicien danois Niels
Bohr.
Cette prescription nous dit que quand on a
une interaction avec un gros objet non-quantique,
un objet classique donc, alors ça compte
comme une mesure.
Un écran, un détecteur, ce genre de choses,
ce sont des gros machins classiques, donc
ça provoque l’effondrement de la fonction
d’onde.
Alors qu’une interaction d’un système
quantique avec un autre système quantique,
par exemple un électron à côté d’un
proton, alors là c’est pas une mesure,
on applique Schrödinger.
Et cette façon de faire, popularisée par
Niels Bohr, fonctionne très bien en pratique.
Mais franchement sur le plan théorique on
a quand même toujours le même problème
: où est la limite ? A partir de quel moment
un truc est assez gros pour être considéré
comme classique ? Pourquoi les deux phénomènes
d’évolution seraient si différents ?
Et puis une chose qu’on s’attendrait avec
la mécanique quantique c’est qu’elle
soit plus fondamentale que la mécanique classique.
Que la mécanique classique découle de la
mécanique quantique.
Un peu comme on peut dire que la gravité
newtonienne découle de la relativité générale.
Avec l’interprétation de Copenhague ça
ne va pas du tout puisque d’après Bohr
on a fondamentalement besoin d’objets classiques
pour donner sens aux règles de la mécanique
quantique.
Donc on tourne en rond, la mécanique quantique
ne peut pas prétendre à être une théorie
fondamentale avec ça.
Voilà, c’est le problème de la mesure.
Et 100 ans après l’invention de la mécanique
quantique, on n’a toujours pas de réponse
claire à y apporter.
Mais rassurez vous, je ne vais pas vous laisser
là, pour finir la vidéo je vais vous esquisser
quelques pistes possibles, en attendant de
faire, j’espère, des épisodes dédiés
sur ces sujets.
Tout d’abord, on pourrait se dire que la
différence n’est peut-être pas si grande
entre les deux règles d’évolution, Schrödinger
et l’effondrement.
Je vous ai dit que dans l’équation de Schrödinger,
le terme H, qu’on appelle Hamiltonien, contient
l’ensemble des influences extérieures.
Quand vous mesurez un électron avec un détecteur,
il y a plein d’influences extérieures qui
s’appliquent sur l’électron, les milliards
de milliards de particules qui composent le
détecteur.
Peut-être que ça donne lieu à un Hamiltonien
très compliqué, qui a l’air un peu aléatoire,
et qui produit une évolution très rapide
qui a l’air instantanée et passe pour effondrement
probabiliste de la fonction d’onde ?
Eh bien non ça ne peut pas marcher.
On le sait à cause d’une propriété de
l’équation de Schrödinger : elle est linéaire.
Je vous passe les détails mais ça montre
qu’on ne peut pas réduire l’effondrement
de la fonction d’onde à une équation de
Schrödinger avec un Hamiltonien très compliqué.
Il faut trouver autre chose.
Le physicien John Bell, l’auteur des célèbres
inégalités dont j’ai déjà pas mal parlé,
aurait résumé les solutions possibles en
disant : il n’y a que deux possibilités
: l’équation de Schrödinger est soit fausse,
soit incomplète.
[SOLUTIONS Une première approche possible,
ce serait donc de fondamentalement modifier
l’équation de Schrödinger pour casser
sa linéarité, et qu’elle puisse vraiment
provoquer des phénomènes d’effondrement
de la fonction d’onde.
Ce sont les approches dites «d’effondrement
objectif». Si on y arrive, ça voudrait
dire que ce qu’il se passe au cours d’une
mesure serait ramené à un cas particulier
de l’évolution selon l’équation de Schrödinger
modifiée.
On aurait plus qu’une seule règle d’évolution.
Mais on peut aussi partir du principe que
l’équation de Schrödinger est toujours
correcte, mais incomplète.
Qu’il faut lui adjoindre d’autres quantités
et d’autres équations.
C’est notamment l’approche que suit la
mécanique Bohmienne, initiée par Louis De
Broglie et développée plus tard par David
Bohm.
Dans le cas le plus simple, elle postule la
coexistence d’une onde et d’une particule,
avec une équation supplémentaire censée
décrire l’interaction entre les deux.
Mais il existe aussi d’autres variantes
similaires sur l’idée d’exhiber ce qu’on
appelle parfois des variables cachées non-locales.]
Avec ces deux familles d’approches, on semble
épuiser l’alternative posée par Bell.
Et pourtant il existe une troisième possibilité.
L’approche d’Everett, des Univers multiples.
[EVERETT Dans cette approche on ne garde que
l’équation de Schrödinger, et sans la
modifier.
Et on explique les mécanismes de mesure par
une séparation en plusieurs branches d’univers.
L’état quantique complet reste superposé,
mais nous n’avons accès qu’à une des
branches de la réalité.]
Ca semble assez bizarre mais c’est très
sérieux, et ça méritera bien une vidéo
dédiée.
Et enfin dernier élément, pour compléter
le tableau, il existe un phénomène très
important, beaucoup étudié sur le plan théorique
et expérimental depuis quelques dizaines
d’années : la décohérence quantique.
Le phénomène de décohérence n’est pas
en soi une proposition de solution au problème
de la mesure.
On ne fait pas d’interprétation particulière
et on n’ajoute rien de nouveau au formalisme.
Mais c’est plutôt l’idée de prendre
sérieusement l’équation de Schrödinger
et de montrer que pour certains systèmes,
les interférences quantiques disparaissent
du fait des interactions avec l’environnement.
La décohérence est une approche valable
quelle que soit l’interprétation que l’on
adopte, c’est «juste» une conséquence
de Schrödinger, mais elle permet d’éclairer
avec une lumière différente ces débats
sur la question de la mesure et des interprétations
de la mécanique quantique.
Donc elle aura aussi sa vidéo dédiée.
Voilà si j’ai bien compté, je viens d’annoncer
4 vidéos, il va falloir que je m’y mette.
Merci d’avoir regardé celle-ci, n’oubliez
pas de vous abonner si c’est pas déjà
le cas, et surtout de mettre la cloche.
Depuis quelques mois chaque vidéo que je
sors fait un démarrage encore plus mauvais
que la précédente et je reçois encore souvent
des messages de gens qui ne voient pas passer
les vidéos et pensent que j’ai complètement
arrêté la chaine.
Alors non, et ça me saoule de devoir rentrer
dans ce jeu là, mais quand même, mettez
la cloche.
Et puis j’espère que comme ça on peut
se retrouver très vite pour une nouvelle
vidéo, à bientôt.